Amy we've heard the rumor in chapter 2
is that really happening uh yeah they're
they're starting to develop and chanted
- it's called disenchanted and that's
for real and yeah they've got a director
attached and they're writing a script I
know you ran it right I'm hoping it
doesn't open at your funeral or
something no I hope not not much yeah I
don't know I can't I don't I'm not gonna
let anybody else play yourself
no no no and that will your daughter be
geeked that you're going back to Giselle
no no she wanted you think here she's
yeah she's so cool I'm mama to her like
she doesn't think of me as an actress at
all like she makes fun of me for it like
when I FaceTime her she's like oh my god
it's yet another way she's getting such
a cool attitude she's like something
janae mommy look oh that's just the
chick that cleans my room and cookies
awesome she's pretty level-headed
because after the Avengers movies
presumably you've got a lot of children
that come up to Jeremy wanting pictures
in there yeah that's the best part of it
all yeah for sure
they you know before the Avengers the
kids would run away from me but now good
I played a superhero gate you know then
they come around and it's the most
amazing thing but why did you frighten
children it just it's really fun it's
his resting face it's very it's a
resting face I was born with and you
know I built a career around it so it's
awesome so right now right now you look
kind of twinkly well cuz I'm smiling
yeah but what I'm just thinking about
like hey that is a really amazing
looking suit
you think that go my god it's a
beautiful shoot but yeah but if I'd you
know if I'm just thinking about it looks
like I might want to choke you yes yes I
see it
is scary yeah yes what's the thing about
your daughter wanting to make you cry oh
we were talking about what I do for a
living and and I was explaining how I
try to make my I just make-believe like
she does when she plays and she's like
can you make yourself laugh and I see
that she goes can you make yourself cry
and I said yeah and she goes to do it
obviously gotta give me a story so we
made up a story and I've done it before
for people about sriracha I don't want
to go back into this grandma no no no
okay
what is the sriracha plan is um they're
shutting it down because the fumes kind
of go into the community and yeah but
I've done this this is redundant it's
really weird leaving completely weird it
out there like I don't trust her yeah
like that that's me yeah yeah it's
always gonna be huh Jim is it you should
be an actress I know yeah we can do that
why'd you Chris her dad you can make
yourself cry yeah good cry cue now go
there's this a rush if time
that
no I don't know I can I can I guess I
don't know if I can make myself cry I do
that thing where definitely if you're in
the midst of the scene you can start you
know yeah if you're really in it it's
kind of fine and you but then when you
get to you guys know on to take kind of
15 or 16 then you got to start playing
some tricks to make your subconscious
cry or something and you start thinking
of signs or for me it's like like
Battersea Dogs Home commercial or for
some reason I don't know why because I'm
a pacifist I keep watching these videos
on YouTube of like soldiers coming back
from war and seeing their animals have
you seen yes it's a killer so when I
like sometimes when you're watching me
on screen that's what I'm thinking
[Music]